[Music]
from joss whedon god of the Nerds comes
the movie blockbuster that finally
unites the world's greatest superheroes
that Marvel still has the rights to the
Avengers the ultimate to our geek
fantasy that blinds all nerds from
admitting any legitimate criticism and
put all of DC Comics on suicide watch a
villain who inexplicably returns from
the dead will foul vengeance on the plan
where his demigod brothers sort of
girlfriend lives forcing this bluetooth
obsessed government agency to assemble
the heroes from Marvel's greatest
franchises except spider-man Fantastic
Four and x-men suit up with Iron Man
everyone's favorite secondary Marvel
character who must redeem himself from
the god-awful Iron Man 2 Thor who's sort
of fooled off his own movie but whose
appearance here completely negates its
ending Captain America no one's favorite
character who just kinda has to be there
and The Incredible Hulk who for the sake
of the plot can now suddenly control his
rage among them
without any explanation which doesn't
matter cuz that shot was awesome
witness being excitement I need you to
get to that pension control Pamela
fireman repairing a spaceship for 20
minutes
the thrill of generic aliens on flying
jet skis that confusing energy source of
the tesseract
Tessera can fight you can protecting
them and it's completely unjustified
fail-safe the explosion that instantly
kills every alien conveniently tying up
all loose edges to the bromance and the
character in the middle of the credits
who every nerd in the audience pretended
to know a movie so fulfilling you won't
remember that the first 45 minutes are
actually kind of boring a villain so
determined
you need the cube to bring me out
you'll wonder why he's uniting the only
people who can stop him in hopes of
getting them to dislike each other
not replan battle so action-packed he
won't even ask yourself how are they
even all talking to each other without
earpieces do it no wait start these
things are still coming pinkeye
Ironman poopy not Edward Norton the
Human Torch leather gurus mace windu and
gabe a Marvel's The Avengers if this
doesn't make your inner eight-year-old
self squeal in delight you're likely
dead inside or a girl if you like honest
trailers then please check out our brand
new weekly series the screen junkies
show seriously don't be a jerk we worked
real hard on this new show so check it
out and leave a comment and as always
leave a comment with the movie you'd
like to see Kat the honest treatment
next cats with boobies oppa Gangnam
style hey I just met you and this is
crazy but here's my number so call me
maybe